Jake:开机啦
Jake: Power on!
Lucia:迅速进入角色
Lucia: Quickly get into character.
刘婷:你看你看
Liu Ting: Look, look!
刘婷:无所谓拍的好不好无所谓
Liu Ting: Doesn't matter if it's good or not, doesn't matter.
刘婷:重在参与好不好 重在参与
Liu Ting: It's all about participation, right? It's all about participation.
刘婷:有信心吗
Liu Ting: Are you confident?
Lucia:没有
Lucia: No.
刘婷:没有我不
Liu Ting: No, I don't...
刘婷:你要有
Liu Ting: You have to be.
Alice:有
Alice: Yes, I am.
Lucia:响亮的答案没有
Lucia: The loud answer is no.
刘婷:要有要有要有
Liu Ting: You have to be, you have to be, you have to be.
刘婷:OK我们看一下我们看一下
Liu Ting: OK, let's take a look, let's take a look.
Lucia:我们没有
Lucia: We don't have it.
Jack: 可以啊
Jack: That's fine.
Jake: 你要变身
Jake: You need to transform.
刘婷:你看一下位置
Liu Ting: Check the position.
Katrina:  靖康导师导师我可以拿这个拍张照吗
Katrina: Teacher Jingkang, can I take a picture with this?
Jake:啊 没问题你自己改 你随便改
Jake: Ah, no problem, you can change it yourself, change it however you like.
Alice:那我不就是最明显的那个了
Alice: Then I'll be the most obvious one.
Jake:你随便改一下都可以
Jake: Change it however you like, it's all good.
刘婷:我我我侧面侧侧过来侧过来
Liu Ting: I, I, I, turn to the side, turn to the side.
Katrina: 哈哈哈看哪光好
Katrina: Haha, look where the light is good.
刘婷:侧过来就是我可以站稍微远一点吗
Liu Ting: Turn to the side, can I stand a little farther?
Jack: 这这黄哪光都那样
Jack: The light's the same everywhere.
Jake: 可以打光要不要搬出来
Jake: We can use lighting, should we bring it out?
Jake:那我搬出来
Jake: Then I'll bring it out.
Jack: 那可以
Jack: That works.
Jake:那我搬出来
Jake: Then I'll bring it out.
Alice: 那这边不就没地了
Alice: Then there won't be space here.
Shure:   那个那谁
Shure: That, that, who...
Shure:  有人给我啊
Shure: Someone give it to me, yeah.
Shure:  你喊我给你送东西
Shure: You call me and I'll bring you the stuff.
Shure:  然后你说你放在那个男生宿舍就行
Shure: Then you said to leave it in the boys' dorm.
刘婷:OK来看下准备
Liu Ting: OK, let's check the preparations.
Shure:  我最开始以为我没寻思你在
Shure: At first, I didn't think you were there.
Shure:  我本来想着就是光着膀子就过去了
Shure: I was originally planning to go shirtless.
Alice:行了吗
Alice: Is it done?
Shure:  你知道吧
Shure: You know?
Shure的女友:我没有我不
Shure's GF: I don't, I don't...
刘婷:OK差不多
Liu Ting: OK, almost done.
Shure的女友:我印象我没有碰到你
Shunyu: I don't remember bumping into you.
刘婷:来来来
Liu Ting: Come on, come on.
Shure的女友:那次是因为我们当时社会实践
Shunyu: That time it was because of our social practice.
刘婷:差不多然然后你咱咱分散开
Liu Ting: Almost, then we split up.
Shure的女友:然后要开个会嘛
Shunyu: And we had a meeting.
Shure的女友:然后整个组的话是只有我跟培训员
Shunyu: And the whole group was just me and the trainer.
刘婷:你左边一个
Liu Ting: One on your left.
刘婷:我右边一个
Liu Ting: One on my right.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈我是导演
Katrina: Hahaha, I'm the director.
刘婷:我们先熟悉的伴奏好不好好
Liu Ting: Let's get familiar with the accompaniment first, okay?
Shure的女友:反正我能去
Shunyu: Anyway, I can go.
Shure的女友:反正我那个头发无所谓了
Shunyu: Anyway, my hair doesn't matter anymore.
Alice: 好
Alice: Okay.
Shure的女友:当时刚剪掉特别短
Shunyu: I had just cut it really short back then.
Katrina:  哇哦哈哈哈
Katrina: Wow, hahaha.
Lucia:哇哦哈哈
Lucia: Wow, haha.
Katrina:  红点是什么
Katrina: What's the red dot?
Alice: 我天天拍这种低智视频
Alice: I film these low-IQ videos every day.
Shure的女友:然后就完全可以去
Shunyu: So I can totally go.
Katrina: 啊 对焦
Katrina: Ah, focusing.
Katrina:  太专业了
Katrina: So professional.
Alice:他的座右铭就是看低智视频
Alice: His motto is to watch low-IQ videos.
Katrina: 但就第一天用了知道吗这个后来就没有
Katrina: But only used it the first day, you know? Not after that.
Alice:想低智人生
Alice: To think low-IQ life.
Lucia:哈哈我以为是享高智人生呢
Lucia: Haha, I thought it was to enjoy high-IQ life.
Alice:哈哈我以为是想高智人生
Alice: Haha, I thought it was to think high-IQ life.
Jack: 你们难道你们并不是
Jack: Aren't you guys...
Shure的女友:然后我在这跟个景点然后就是
Shunyu: And then I'm here like a tourist spot and...
Shure的女友:我基本上他宿舍周围我认识的人
Shunyu: I basically know the people around his dorm.
Katrina:  我以为第一天很正式
Katrina: I thought the first day was very formal.
刘婷:6来来来合并
Liu Ting: Come on, let's merge.
Shure的女友:然后都要过来啊
Shunyu: And everyone has to come over.
Jake: 姐 帮帮忙呗
Jake: Sis, can you help me out?
Tasha:说
Tasha: Tell me.
Jake: 那个一会我们一起
Jake: Later we...
Jake: 把充电宝给 不是 插电板给弄下来
Jake: Let's take down the power strip.
Tasha:好呀
Tasha: Sure.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:我去
Jake: I'm going.
Shure的女友:no no no no
Shure's GF: no no no no
Lucia:然后下一个是我是吧
Lucia: And then it's my turn, right?
Lucia:啊这样子
Lucia: Ah, like this
Lucia:然后还是接着动啊哈哈
Lucia: And still moving, haha
Alice: 玩不了一点哈哈哈
Alice: Can't play at all, haha
Jack: 你们这个
Jack: You guys are...
刘婷:存个草稿
Liu Ting: Save a draft
Jake: 呃我拉插线板会长一点
Jake: Uh, my extension cord is a bit longer
Alice:看看
Alice: Let's see
Jack: 他色温可以调吗
Jack: Can you adjust its color temperature?
Jake:我不会了
Jake: I can't
Jake: 他很便宜啊
Jake: It's very cheap
Jack: 那就这样了
Jack: Then that's it
Jake: 好嘞 能强点是吧
Jake: Alright, can it be stronger?
Jack: 不是 色温可以重新
Jack: No, the color temperature can be reset
刘婷:存草稿吧存草稿
Liu Ting: Save a draft, save a draft
刘婷:有信心吗
Liu Ting: Are you confident?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Katrina: 看补光灯有效果没
Katrina: Check if the fill light has an effect
Lucia:没有
Lucia: No
Lucia:响亮的答复 没有
Lucia: Loud and clear, no
Tasha:哇靠
Tasha: Wow
Alice: 反正有个草稿了
Alice: Anyway, we have a draft
Tasha: 哎他 不是
Tasha: Hey, he... no
Jake:你说
Jake: Go ahead
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What?
Jake:什么什么东西
Jake: What, what?
Tasha:啊 没有人吧 我就是好奇一下
Tasha: Ah, nobody, I was just curious
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What?
Jake:那个学姐照样
Jake: That senior...
Jake: 哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh
Tasha:哦
Tasha: Oh
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Ah
Tasha:没有关系
Tasha: It doesn't matter
Jake:我不知道
Jake: I don't know
Jake:我不知道 我真不知道
Jake: I don't know, I really don't know.
Jake: 我们
Jake: We
Jake: 我们工作上
Jake: We at work
Jake: 哈哈哈保持工作上的联系
Jake: Hahaha, we keep in touch at work.
Tasha: 是吗
Tasha: Really?
Tasha:只 只 只
Tasha: Just, just, just
Tasha:好吧
Tasha: Okay.
Jake: 也不是 我没问过我也没太懂
Jake: Not really, I never asked, so I don't really understand.
Tasha:要干嘛呀
Tasha: What are you doing?
Jake:呃 拔掉
Jake: Uh, unplug it.
Jake: 我去拔我去拔
Jake: I'll unplug it, I'll do it.
Tasha:这个嘛
Tasha: This one?
Tasha:这个吗
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Tasha:the
Tasha: the
Jake:the
Jake: the
Tasha:the
Tasha: the
Jake:the
Jake: the
Tasha:this
Tasha: this
Tasha:and the
Tasha: and the
Tasha:我靠你就不能买个长的吗
Tasha: Oh my god, couldn't you buy a longer one?
Tasha:你买俩小短的
Tasha: You bought two short ones.
Jake: 嘿嘿
Jake: Hehe
Jake:经费有限
Jake: Budget is limited.
Tasha:OK
Tasha: OK
Tasha: 他们在拍照
Tasha: They are taking pictures.
Alice:你要从这到那要多久
Alice: How long does it take you to get from here to there?
女嘉宾:从哪到哪
Female guest: From where to where?
Lucia:不是修硕要跳舞来着的吗
Lucia: Isn't Shure supposed to dance?
Alice: 就是你坐你的公交公共交通
Alice: Like, when you take public transportation.
女嘉宾:十来分钟吧
Female guest: About ten minutes.
Lucia:不是修硕要干好多事来着吗
Lucia: Isn't Shure supposed to do a lot of things?
Alice:哦那还好
Alice: Oh, that's not bad.
Katrina:  哈哈哈核心主力吗
Katrina: Hahaha, a key player?
Tasha:还好
Tasha: Not bad.
Alice:累吗哎等下下
Alice: Tired? Hey, wait a second.
Shure:  我怕回去他不认我了
Shure: I'm afraid he won't recognize me when I go back.
Katrina: 哈哈你跳个舞她也跟你和好了
Katrina: Haha, if you dance, she'll make up with you.
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Tasha:好
Tasha: Okay.
Shure: 他分在哪跳啊
Shure: Where is he jumping from?
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure的女友:哎 你别说他小时候学过
Shure's GF: Hey, don't say that, he learned it when he was young.
Katrina:  他学什么舞种
Katrina: What kind of dance did he learn?
Alice:好神经啊
Alice: So crazy.
Shure的女友:你问他咯
Shure's GF: You should ask him.
Katrina:  不会学拉丁吧
Katrina: He didn't learn Latin dance, did he?
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Tasha:我什么都没干我在
Tasha: I didn't do anything, I was just here.
Nicous: 我们去打英雄联盟
Nicous: We went to play League of Legends.
Tasha:真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Alice: 送你一下吧
Alice: Let me see you off.
Alice: 我要去送他一下
Alice: I need to see him off.
Tasha: 杨老板把我感下来记我来记录生活
Tasha: Jake asked me to record this to document my life.
Nicous: 对
Nicous: Right.
Shure:  老板要给你开三万块钱
Shure: The boss is going to pay you 30,000.
Tasha: 好的他要给我开3万块钱一个月
Tasha: Okay, he's going to pay me 30,000 a month.
Tasha: 你知道吗
Tasha: Did you know that?
Jake:拜拜拜拜
Jake: Bye-bye, bye-bye.
Katrina:  你再说他要破防要破防
Katrina: If you keep saying that, he'll get upset.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Tasha: 他说他要给我开3万块一个月
Tasha: He said he's going to pay me 30,000 a month.
Shure的女友:他刚刚已经没理我
Shure's GF: He just ignored me just now.
刘婷:哦哟 慢点慢点
Liu Ting: Oh, slow down, slow down.
Katrina: 抽一根
Katrina: Take a smoke.
Alice:那我就录着这个走啦
Alice: Then I'll record this while walking.
Jake:好好好
Jake: Okay, okay, okay.
Alice:拜拜
Alice: Bye-bye.
Jake:拜拜拜拜
Jake: Bye-bye, bye-bye.
Shure的女友:我昨天下午这个时候发消息
Shure's GF: I sent a message at this time yesterday afternoon.
Violet: 这两个gester走了吗
Violet: Did those two guests leave?
Jake: 对 两个gester送走
Jake: Yes, the two guests left.
Katrina: 现在几点钟了
Katrina: What time is it now?
Jake: 送走两位gester
Jake: Sent off the two guests.
女嘉宾:现在7.30了
Female Guest: It's 7:30 now.
Katrina: 我们预计八点结束还没有唱一首歌
Katrina: We planned to finish by 8, but we haven't sung a song yet.
女嘉宾:让她唱一首结束呗
Female Guest: Let her sing a song to end it.
Shure的女友:不是我不是他们在哦
Shure's GF: Not me, they're still here.
女嘉宾:一首就5分钟
Female Guest: One song is just 5 minutes.
Katrina: 你还没表演你的才艺呢
Katrina: You haven't performed your talent yet.
Nicous: 可以啊
Nicous: Sure.
Katrina: 你的电钢琴啊
Katrina: Your electric piano.
Lucia:相信您的技术
Lucia: I believe in your skills.
Nicous: 太简单了
Nicous: Too easy.
Nicous: 难忘今宵已经练好了
Nicous: I've already practiced "Unforgettable Tonight."
Nicous: 这配上修出的那个笔记本的音效
Nicous: This with the sound effects from Shure's laptop.
Nicous: 太屌了
Nicous: It's awesome.
Lucia:哎我觉得这张很好对对对
Lucia: Hey, I think this one is great, yes, yes.
男嘉宾:你拍我脸干嘛呀
Male Guest: Why are you filming my face?
女嘉宾:这打光自拍
Female Guest: It's for a selfie with good lighting.
Lucia:最后最后那张就是我
Lucia: The last one, the last one, that's me.
Lucia:就是那个角度的话
Lucia: That angle though,
Lucia:我的脸型会有点有点胖
Lucia: Makes my face look a bit chubby.
Lucia:但是前面几张都很好
Lucia: But the previous ones are all good.
Jake: 还没开始呢就让我清场
Jake: We haven't even started yet, and you're already asking me to clear the room.
Jake: 别忘了那三首歌啊 我靠 哈哈哈
Jake: Don't forget those three songs! Oh my gosh, haha.
Lucia:没事没事可以了
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay, that's fine.
Lucia: 谢谢谢谢
Lucia: Thank you, thank you.
Katrina:  修硕
Katrina: Shure.
Jake: 修硕你选的三首歌了
Jake: Shure, the three songs you picked.
Lucia:我觉得你们拍得很好很好
Lucia:只有偶偶然有发挥失误的时候也很正常是吧
Lucia: It's normal to occasionally have some performance errors, right?
Jake: 修硕你选的三首歌呢
Jake: Shure, your three chosen songs.
Shure: 我选的三首歌
Shure: The three songs I picked.
Katrina: 一起唱呗
Katrina: Let's sing together.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: new boy这首
Katrina: The song "New Boy."
Shure:  我们
Shure: We.
Shure的女友：那时候是我们俩
Shure's GF: At that time, it was just the two of us.
Shure: 收费啊收费
Shure: Charge, charge.
Jake: 那能是
Jake: That's impossible.
Shure的女友:拍你们不行吗
Shure's GF: Can't I film you guys?
Jack: 你俩是唯一正经的情侣
Jack: You two are the only serious couple here.
Shure: 什么叫正经
Shure: What do you mean by serious?
Shure: 你们这些回去都不能说是吧
Shure: You all can't say anything when you go back, right?
Tasha:正经
Tasha: Serious.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Shure的女友:我们这都不是CP
Shure's GF: We're not even a couple.
Shure: 哦好好好
Shure: Oh, alright, alright.
男嘉宾:我们我们这个
Male Guest: We, we, this
Katrina: 我看用手机拍
Katrina: I see, let's use a phone to take pictures.
Shure的女友:咦不要
Shure's GF: Oh no, don't.
Katrina:  我试试给你们拍一组壁纸出来
Katrina: I'll try to take some wallpapers for you.
Jake:两个ego币
Jake: Two ego coins.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah
Tasha: 聚光会就是显得面部平整度很高啊
Tasha: The spotlight makes the face look very smooth.
Jake:现在也挺好的是不是
Jake: It's pretty good right now, isn't it?
Jake:蹲下去了这个就不行了
Jake: If you squat down, it won't work.
女嘉宾:这有点挡住了就没关系
Female Guest: If it's a bit blocked, it's no big deal.
Shure的女友:呵呵sorry尊重摄影师好吗
Shure's GF: Haha, sorry, respect the photographer, okay?
Tasha:没关系
Tasha: It's okay.
Shure:  怎怎么看摄影师
Shure: How do you look at the photographer?
女嘉宾:怎么看
Female Guest: How do you look?
女嘉宾:哈你
Female Guest: Ha you
男嘉宾:就你随便看个地方吧
Male Guest: Just look anywhere you want.
男嘉宾:没有入镜
Male Guest: Not in the shot.
男嘉宾:看地上然后你看啊
Male Guest: Look at the ground, then look up.
Tasha:你就差一点
Tasha: You're just a bit off.
女嘉宾:来来来三个人
Female Guest: Come on, three of us.
Katrina: 哈哈不准笑场
Katrina: Haha, don't laugh.
女嘉宾:可以
Female Guest: Okay.
Shure的女友:就是我们俩这个情况比较复杂
Shure's GF: Our situation is a bit complicated.
Shure的女友:你知道吗
Shure's GF: You know?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
Jack: 什么情况比较复杂
Jack: What do you mean complicated?
Jake:啊什么叫复杂什么叫复杂
Jake: Ah, what do you mean complicated, what do you mean complicated?
Jack: 什么叫复杂
Jack: What do you mean complicated?
Tasha:他这个应该角是落就是
Tasha: He should be at the angle where it's like...
Katrina: 拍 拍 拍到非公开群里
Katrina: Take, take, take it to the private group.
男嘉宾:哪里复杂
Male Guest: What's complicated?
Tasha:这是
Tasha: It's...
Shure的女友:sorry
Shure's GF: Sorry.
Shure的女友:不是他看我我看他
Shure's GF: It's not him looking at me, me looking at him.
Tasha: 天呢
Tasha: Oh my god.
Jake: 你要给我们送一集多少信息
Jake: How much information are you going to send us?
Tasha: 没事
Tasha: It's fine.
女嘉宾:好看呐可以截一下
Female Guest: Looks good, you can take a screenshot.
Jack: 怎么复杂
Jack: What's complicated?
Jake:咱能飙一下午咱能飙得了不
Jake: Can we do this all afternoon or not?
Jack: 复杂在哪
Jack: What's complicated about it?
Jake:咱能飙得了不
Jake: Can we speed it up?
Lucia:可以选一下帧
Lucia: We can select the frame.
Lucia:因为那个动
Lucia: Because it moves.
Jack: 到时候到时候这涉及到一个问题
Jack: At that time, this involves a question.
Tasha: 好的好的
Tasha: Okay, okay.
Tasha: 好谢谢谢谢
Tasha: Alright, thank you, thank you.
Jack: 发给修硕填填填答案呢
Jack: Send it to Shure to fill in the answers.
Tasha: 那就行
Tasha: That'll work.
Lucia:可以啊
Lucia: Sure.
Jack: 那个灰鸟灰得什么情况笑场
Jack: What's with the gray bird, it's making us laugh.
Lucia:眼睛会有点反光是
Lucia: The eyes are a bit reflective.
Tasha:唉
Tasha: Sigh.
男嘉宾:你不要你不能抬那么长
Male Guest: You can't lift it that high.
男嘉宾:你不能抬那么多头
Male Guest: You can't lift your head that much.
男嘉宾:你俩能互相看一下吗
Male Guest: Can you two look at each other?
Lucia:这样看好像有点暗
Lucia: It looks a bit dark this way.
男嘉宾:快快快
Male Guest: Hurry, hurry.
Jake:哎呀妈
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Jack: 这这个看法不太不太正常
Jack: This view is not quite normal.
Katrina: 你俩别整的像暧昧气一样行吗
Katrina: You two, don't act so flirty, okay?
Jack: 你们俩搞得像你们俩
Jack: You two are acting like...
Lucia:可以可以可以选一下帧
Lucia: Sure, sure, we can select the frame.
Jack: 现在还在害羞非常暧昧
Jack: Still shy, very flirty.
Shure:  没有
Shure: No, we're not.
Jack: 所以是暧昧期吗
Jack: So, is this the flirty phase?
Lucia:不过你可以选一下帧
Lucia: But you can select the frame.
Katrina: 还老夫老妻了暧昧去
Katrina: Acting like an old couple in the flirty phase.
Jack: 啊
Jack: Huh?
Lucia:我自拍的时候其实不知道应该看哪
Lucia: When I take selfies, I don't know where to look.
Jack: 看着也不像啊
Jack: Doesn't look like it.
Jake:多久了 我也不懂我也不懂
Jake: How long has it been? I don't get it.
男嘉宾:我也不懂我也很好奇
Male Guest: I don't get it, I'm curious too.
Jake:回去你自己飙啊
Jake: Go home and speed it up yourself.
男嘉宾:最后两张
Male Guest: The last two shots.
Jake: 哈哈哈 我是飙不了的
Jake: Haha, I can't speed it up.
Jack: 到正到时问起就哎放
Jack: Ask at the right time and just go.
Jake:这玩意彪不了啦
Jake: This thing can't be rushed.
Shure的女友:干嘛给自己
Shure: Why give it to yourself?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:我们俩总有一个人模糊拍
Lucia: One of us always ends up blurry in the photos.
Jake:拍破防了 我草
Jake: This photo broke my defense, damn.
Lucia:对这张还行
Lucia: Yeah, this one is okay.
Jake:拍到了吧是吧
Jake: Did we get it?
男嘉宾:ok
Male Guest: Ok.
Jake:反正我们是都录了
Jake: Anyway, we recorded everything.
男嘉宾:没电了
Male Guest: Battery's dead.
Jake:噢
Jake: Oh.
男嘉宾:看不见
Male Guest: Can't see it.
Jack: 没事还有电而且还有很多电呢
Jack: It's fine, we still have plenty of battery.
Jake: 挺好
Jake: Good.
Lucia:对这张好像反光弱一些
Lucia: Yeah, this one seems to have less glare.
Shure: 是的都是我们配的一环
Shure: Yep, it's all part of our setup.
Jake:我觉得是第一个学习机里有接吻片的
Jake: I think this is the first learning device with a kissing scene.
Jake: 第一视角接吻照片
Jake: A first-person view kissing photo.
Jack: 我刚我刚错过了什么
Jack: What did I just miss?
Jake:马上给他们看一眼
Jake: Let me show them quickly.
Shure:  所有那个学生会议都要邀请我俩去亲一下是吧
Shure: So all the student meetings will invite us to kiss, right?
Jack: 我刚错过了什么
Jack: What did I just miss?
Tasha: 这里面有 上一张
Tasha: It's in here, the previous one.
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Shure:  对对对 上一张
Shure: Yeah, yeah, the previous one.
Jake:我们第一张图片配合第一张图片就是这个哇
Jake: Our first picture matches the first picture, which is wow.
Jack: 让我看看 来来来先先
Jack: Let me see, come on, show me.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Jack: 哦
Jack: Oh.
Katrina:  拍到了吗看看
Katrina: Did we get it? Let's see.
Jack: 哦
Jack: Oh.
Jake:啊好妙啊
Jake: Ah, this is amazing.
Jack: 看了一下正点啊
Jack: Looks great, right on time.
Shure的女友:分手了只要钱到位也没关系
Shure: It's okay to break up as long as the money's in place. 社会问题
Katrina: 哇
Katrina: Wow.
Katrina: 哇 来给我拍一张
Katrina: Wow, come take a picture of me.
Lucia:对 我觉得这边这个好一点
Lucia: Yeah, I think this one is better.
Shure: 可以可以过去在亲的这是没有问题
Shure: Sure, you can go over and kiss, no problem.
Jack: 分手一钱给到位也没问题
Jack: Breaking up is fine as long as the money is right. 社会问题
Nicous: 分手了也没有关系吗
Nicous: Is it really okay to break up?
Katrina:  是发群里吧
Katrina: Are we posting it in the group?
Katrina:  发群里公开
Katrina: Post it in the group publicly.
Jack: 没问题 没问题
Jack: No problem, no problem.
Jake:没问题
Jake: No problem.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Jack: 全部都交给露亚了啊
Jack: Leave everything to Lucia.
Shure的女友:要不然怎么会说情况很复杂呢
Shure's GF: Otherwise, why would they say it's complicated?
Jake:还有四张图
Jake: There are four more pictures.
Lucia:好好好我都
Lucia: Okay, okay, I...
男嘉宾:有经验了都
Male Guest: I've got experience.
Lucia:我都发到群里你可以建一个文件夹
Lucia: I'll send them to the group, you can create a folder.
Katrina: 不是哥们不玩了走了
Katrina: No, man, I'm not playing anymore, I'm leaving.
Jake:哦哦差了四张图是吧
Jake: Oh, we're missing four pictures, right?
男嘉宾:拍四张类型的拼过去
Male Guest: Take four types of pictures and stitch them together.
Lucia:然后我直接转发到群里
Lucia: Then I'll just forward them to the group.
Jake:OK  OK
Jake: OK, OK.
Jake: 妙
Jake: Great.
男嘉宾:那看来是非常的复杂
Male Guest: It seems really complicated.
Jack: 这关系真的是很复杂
Jack: This relationship is really complicated.
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Ah.
女嘉宾:可以发给我
Female Guest: You can send it to me.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:抽两根要
Jake: Let's have two.
Jack: 这Paty活动适合拍照
Jack: This party event is perfect for taking pictures.
Jake: 该唱歌的人在那呢
Jake: The person who should be singing is over there.
男嘉宾:唱歌唱歌
Male Guest: Sing, sing.
Jake:该唱歌的人在这整活了
Jake: The person who should be singing is busy with something.
Jack: 唱啊开唱唱唱唱唱
Jack: Sing, go ahead, sing, sing, sing, sing.
Jake:整活了太忙了
Jake: Busy with something.
Lucia:啊好的好的没问题不发原图
Lucia: Ah, okay, okay, no problem, I won't send the original pictures.
Shure: 我们要唱什么来着
Shure: What are we supposed to sing?
Shure: 是不是说说说给大家
Shure: Shouldn't we tell everyone?
Shure: 我的我的我的teammates
Shure: My, my, my teammates.
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Ah.
Shure:  我的我的roommates呢
Shure: My, my roommates.
Shure:  roommates上里面调小药水去了
Shure: Roommates went to get some drinks.
Jake: 这这你调酒去了
Jake: You're making drinks?
Lucia:你有teammates你不是说好了我自己solo吗
Lucia: You have teammates? Didn't you say I would solo?
女嘉宾:不是说好了我自己solo吗
Female Guest: Didn't you say I would solo?
Jake:solo 对呀
Jake: Solo, right.
Shure: 什么solo不是
Shure: What solo? No.
Jake:solo dancer
Jake: Solo dancer.
Shure: 唉
Shure: Oh.
Tasha: 可以可以
Tasha: Sure, sure.
Tasha: 没关系你想要哪张就哪张
Tasha: No problem, you can choose whichever one you want.
女嘉宾:给个这个吧
Female guest: Give me this one.
Tasha: 我哪一张都可以
Tasha: Any one is fine with me.
女嘉宾:我的脸都差不多
Female guest: My face looks about the same in all of them.
Tasha: 没关系我哪张都可以
Tasha: No problem, any one is fine with me.
Shure: 不不上去还是在下边上去是吗
Shure: So, are we going up or staying down here?
女嘉宾:好的好的
Female guest: Okay, okay.
Jake: 哎都行听你的
Jake: Oh, whatever you say.
Jack: 都行啊
Jack: Yeah, whatever.
Jake: 行在下面呆着吧
Jake: Alright, let's just stay down here.
Lucia:现在是
Lucia: Now it's
Lucia:7点 哇
Lucia: 7 o'clock, wow.
Lucia:已经都7:40了快
Lucia: It's almost 7:40 already.
女嘉宾:那两个guest已经走了
Female guest: Those two guests have already left.
Tasha:guest
Tasha: Guests?
女嘉宾:guest
Female guest: Guests.
Lucia:这个柯欣的guest
Lucia: Kohin's guests.
Tasha:都到了呀
Tasha: Everyone's here.
Shure: 在上面吧
Shure: Upstairs, I guess.
Jake:哎呀要上去了
Jake: Oh, we need to go up.
Shure: 他在上面活动
Shure: He's moving around upstairs.
Tasha:怎么回事
Tasha: What's going on?
Tasha:我上来他们下来我也来他们上来
Tasha: I come up, they go down, and when I go down, they come up.
Jake:没逗你
Jake: Not joking with you.
Jake:可没逗您
Jake: Seriously, not joking.
Jake:薇薇走了
Jake: Tasha left.
Jake:薇薇
Jake: Tasha.
Jake:姐
Jake: Sis.
Jake:薇薇
Jake: Tasha.
Tasha:不要感我姐
Tasha: Don't call me sis.
Jake:那喊你什么呀
Jake: Then what should I call you?
Jake:怎么不戴眼镜
Jake: Why aren't you wearing glasses?
Tasha:因为在做
Tasha: Because I'm doing...
Jake:啊
Jake: Huh?
Jake:因为在做什么
Jake: Because you're doing what?
Tasha:不要喊我姐我比你小吧
Tasha: Don't call me sis, I'm younger than you, right?
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:好 征求你说
Jake: Okay, I'll ask for your opinion.
Tasha:你几几年的
Tasha: Which year were you born?
Jake:我95年的
Jake: I was born in '95.
Tasha:好 哥
Tasha: Okay, bro.
Jake:好  走
Jake: Alright, let’s go.
Jake:全民k歌
Jake: Karaoke for everyone.
Jake:请
Jake: Please.
Tasha:去楼上干啥
Tasha: What are we doing upstairs?
Jake:我
Jake: I...
Tasha:我不会唱歌
Tasha: I can't sing.
Jake:没关系我也不会
Jake: It's fine, I can't either.
Tasha:那你去干啥
Tasha: Then why are we going?
Jake:去看着 就是活动嘛 走一遍流程
Jake: Just to watch. It's an event, we’re going through the motions.
Tasha:好吧 石头剪刀布
Tasha: Alright, rock-paper-scissors.
Jake:对 走
Jake: Right, let's go.
Jake:然后呢
Jake: And then?
Tasha:我赢了的话
Tasha: If I win...
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah?
Tasha:你就扶我下来
Tasha: You have to help me down.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha:我输了的话
Tasha: If I lose...
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah?
Tasha:你就扶着凳子
Tasha: You just hold the chair.
Jake:噢 好行 来
Jake: Oh, alright. Come on.
Tasha:不行
Tasha: No way.
Tasha:三局两胜 哈哈哈
Tasha: Best two out of three, haha.
Tasha:好
Tasha: Alright.
Jake:好 扶你下来
Jake: Okay, I'll help you down.
Jake:怎么扶
Jake: How do I help?
Tasha:不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know.
Jake:那请您 请您
Jake: Then please, please...
Jake:怎么怎么清
Jake: How do I do it?
Tasha:不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know.
Jake:那有点难喂
Jake: This is kinda tough.
Jake:哈哈哈我去
Jake: Haha, here we go.
Tasha:我赢了
Tasha: I won.
Jake:怎么怎么清下来着
Jake: How do I get you down?
Tasha:不知道
Tasha: No idea.
Jake:好难啊
Jake: This is hard.
Jake:请您下来
Jake: Please come down.
Jake:来
Jake: Come on.
Tasha:行行行
Tasha: Alright, alright.
Tasha:我害怕
Tasha: I'm scared.
Jake:唉 我去 还是还是这么下来了
Jake: Oh man, I still came down like this.
Tasha:好吧
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:好
Jake:行
Jake: Got it.
Tasha:嗯  好
Tasha: Mm, okay.
Shure: 对着点我嘴
Shure: Point it at my mouth.
Shure: 话筒一点升收不进去
Shure: The microphone isn't picking it up.
Jack: ok ok说声对不起
Jack: Ok, ok, say sorry.
Shure: 哈哈哈喂喂哎
Shure: Hahaha, hello, hello.
Jake:在大屏幕上放词
Jake: Put the lyrics on the big screen.
Katrina: 这是这是
Katrina: This is, this is...
Katrina: 这是彩排啊
Katrina: This is a rehearsal, right?
Shure: 哈哈哈刚才是试音好吧
Shure: Hahaha, we were just testing the sound.
男嘉宾:主要是试音
Male Guest: Mainly testing the sound.
Shure: 好吧也也能看到
Shure: Alright, it's visible too.
Katrina: 试音
Katrina: Sound test.
男嘉宾:他这个看不到词
Male Guest: He can't see the lyrics.
男嘉宾:对对对
Male Guest: Yes, yes.
Shure: 也也能看到
Shure: It's visible too.
Nicous: 这词有点小
Nicous: The lyrics are a bit small.
男嘉宾:大
Male Guest: Big.
男嘉宾:可以可以
Male Guest: Okay, okay.
Shure: 可以看到可以看到啊
Shure: We can see, we can see it.
男嘉宾:可以看到可以看到
Male Guest: We can see, we can see.
Katrina: OK
Katrina: OK.
Katrina: 那你要面对这边面吗
Katrina: Do you want to face this way?
男嘉宾:那你可以重来还是接着来
Male Guest: Do you want to start over or continue?
Shure: 从头来
Shure: Start over.
男嘉宾:从头来从头来
Male Guest: Start over, start over.
Katrina: 好
Katrina: Okay.
Shure: 保证
Shure: Promise.
Katrina: 有勇气
Katrina: Courage.
Lucia:没事没事这个不是玻璃
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay, this isn't glass.
Shure: 啥玩意碎了
Shure: What broke?
Lucia:这是个啥呀
Lucia: What is this?
女嘉宾:杨老板杨老板
Female Guest: Jake, Jake.
Jake:呃给我给我就好了
Jake: Uh, give it to me, it's fine.
Jake:对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 下一首还有还有下一首
Shure: Next song, there's another song.
Nicous: 加个钢琴
Nicous: Add a piano.
男嘉宾:还有下一首
Male Guest: There's another song.
Katrina: 你想弹什么你弹
Katrina: Play whatever you want to play.
Nicous: 前面加一个钢琴
Nicous: Add a piano at the beginning.
Katrina: 来啊
Katrina: Go ahead.
Jack: 流沙
Jack: Quicksand.
Shure: 我们是不是还说要唱new boy来着啊
Shure: Didn't we say we were going to sing "New Boy"?
Katrina: 都行都行
Katrina: Anything is fine.
Katrina: 反正发现就还是咱几个人
Katrina: Anyway, it's just the few of us.
男嘉宾:唱什么
Male Guest: What to sing?
Katrina: 那随便唱
Katrina: Then sing whatever.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Go ahead.
Jake:对都在掌握中
Jake: Yeah, it's all under control.
Jake:你随便唱
Jake: Sing whatever you like.
Katrina: 一切都在掌握中
Katrina: Everything is under control.
Shure: 那个XBZ你
Shure: Hey, XBZ, you...
Nicous: 你把麦关了
Nicous: Turn off your mic.
Shure: 你 你弹一个D调的卡农的和弦会吗
Shure: Can you play the D major chord for "Canon"?
Nicous: 可以
Nicous: Sure.
Shure: 不不 你就弹D调卡农和弦就行
Shure: No, just play the D major chord for "Canon."
Katrina: 一切都在掌握中
Katrina: Everything is under control.
Nicous: 很高级
Nicous: Very sophisticated.
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly.
Shure: 哎呀歌词就行
Shure: Oh, just the lyrics will do.
Jake:对是其他挺费劲的
Jake: Yeah, everything else is quite tricky.
Shure: 能能能找明白不
Shure: Can you figure it out?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah?
Nicous: 是这个吗
Nicous: Is it this one?
Shure: 差不多吧
Shure: Pretty much.
Shure: 相信你
Shure: I believe in you.
Shure: 第一个是这个
Shure: The first one is this.
Shure: 拍什么曲子
Shure: What song to record?
Shure: new boy
Shure: "New Boy."
Jake:哎薇薇呢
Jake:又翘班了
Jake: Skipping work again.
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Alright, alright, alright.
Jake:不行不行
Jake: No, no.
Jake:翘班不行
Jake: Skipping work is not allowed.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Jake:得上来摸鱼
Jake: You need to come up and slack off.
Jake:翘班不行
Jake: Skipping work is not allowed.
Shure: one
Shure: One.
Shure: two
Shure: Two.
Shure: one two three
Shure: One, two, three.
Shure: 打这个是吗
Shure: Hit this one, right?
Shure: 这个这个
Shure: This one, this one.
Shure: 我从这调
Shure: I'll adjust from here.
Shure: OK 好
Shure: OK, got it.
男嘉宾:喂
Male Guest: Hello?
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
男嘉宾:还有点大
Male Guest: It's still a bit loud.
男嘉宾:稍为有点大得调小点
Male Guest: It's still a bit loud, need to lower it a bit.
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Okay, okay, okay.
Shure: 你的
Shure: Yours.
Jake:下去接妈妈的电话去
Jake: Go downstairs to answer mom's call.
Jake:哈哈哈沙雕
Jake: Haha, you fool.
Jake:来来来
Jake: Come on, come on.
Shure: 行了行了行了可以了可以了
Shure: Alright, alright, alright, that's enough.
Katrina: 哈哈哈谱还没对象
Katrina: Haha, Puh still doesn't have a partner.
Katrina: 结束了
Katrina: It's over.
Shure: 来吧你你的难忘今宵了吧该
Shure: Come on, it's time for your unforgettable tonight.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jack: 啊 谁难忘今宵了
Jack: Ah, who's unforgettable tonight?
Nicous: 那你调下声
Nicous: Then you adjust the sound.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Shure: 人呢还有一个
Shure: Where's the other person?
Shure: 还有一个XBZ同学要为大家带来的一首歌曲
Shure: There's another classmate XBZ who will bring a song for everyone.
Nicous: 谢彬竹和修硕的
Nicous: Xie Bin Zhu and Shure's.
Shure: 没有我没有我
Shure: Not me, not me.
Nicous: 你这比我重要了
Nicous: You're more important than me.
Shure: 我给你选一个好听的音色就好了
Shure: I'll pick you a nice tone, that's all.
Nicous: 给我切换一下
Nicous: Switch it for me.
Nicous: 用手指切换
Nicous: Switch with your finger.
Shure: 来吧XBZ同学
Shure: Come on, classmate XBZ.
Shure: 没有他
Shure: He's not here.
Katrina: 呵呵 这弹出来
Katrina: Haha, it popped out.
男嘉宾:有点想哭了 音乐出来就想哭
Male Guest: I feel like crying, when the music starts I want to cry.
Katrina: 这是背景音吧
Katrina: Is this background music?
男嘉宾:这加了特效音乐
Male Guest: This has special effects music added.
Katrina: 天呐 如听仙月耳在鸣哈哈
Katrina: Oh my God, it sounds like celestial music, haha.
Jack: 准备 准准备开哭
Jack: Get ready, get ready to cry.
Katrina: 这什么歌
Katrina: What song is this?
男嘉宾:难忘今宵
Male Guest: Unforgettable Tonight.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Shure: 今夜我们在此欢聚
Shure: Tonight we are gathered here.
男嘉宾:哎哟喂
Male Guest: Oh boy.
Katrina: 说不清
Katrina: Can't explain it.
Shure: 今夜我们在此快乐
Shure: Tonight we are happy here.
Nicous: 再再来一点
Nicous: A bit more.
男嘉宾:已经开饮一天了
Male Guest: We've been drinking all day.
Alice:这什么环节啊
Alice: What part is this?
Katrina: 忘记今宵
Katrina: Forget Tonight.
Shure的女友:难忘今宵
Female Guest: Unforgettable Tonight.
Jake:赶上clothing了
Jake: Just in time for clothing.
Shure: 我们相聚一堂
Shure: We are gathered together.
Shure: 在这ego house
Shure: In this ego house.
Jack: 什么呀
Jack: What is this?
Alice:有点抽象
Alice: It's kind of abstract.
Jake:我跟你哈哈哈哈
Jake: I'm with you, hahaha.
Jack: 顺间就服气了
Jack: Suddenly, I am convinced.
女嘉宾:你们坐吧
Female Guest: You guys sit down.
Alice:哦对我的衣服没晾哦
Alice: Oh right, I forgot to hang my clothes.
Shure: 我们难忘今宵
Shure: We won't forget tonight.
Shure: 我们难忘未来
Shure: We won't forget the future.
Jack: 难忘未来什么
Jack: Won't forget the future, what?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈你忘什么东西
Jake: Hahaha, what are you forgetting?
Katrina: 还没过呢就难忘
Katrina: It's not even here yet, and you're unforgettable.
Shure: 我们难忘过去
Shure: We won't forget the past.
Shure: 来吧 朋友
Shure: Come on, friends.
Jake:快进门
Jake: Quick, come in.
Shure: 牵着你的手
Shure: Hold your hand.
女嘉宾:要退票了
Female Guest: Want to refund the ticket.
Shure: 就让
Shure: Just let...
Shure: 昨天的烦恼都忘掉
Shure: Forget all the troubles of yesterday.
Shure: 去迎接明天的快乐吧
Shure: Embrace the happiness of tomorrow.
Katrina: 在做心灵SPA啊
Katrina: Doing a mental spa.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Jack: 还啊的一声
Jack: And then there's an "ah" sound.
Alice:我的天
Alice: Oh my god.
Shure: 多好啊
Shure: It's so great.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Nicous: 我有点感觉这个谱子不太对啊
Nicous: I feel like this score isn't quite right.
Shure: 挺好的
Shure: It's pretty good.
男嘉宾:没有
Male Guest: No.
Shure: 这个我们就叫做离谱对吧
Shure: We just call this ridiculous, right?
Jack: 没有
Jack: No.
Jack: 滚你这看起来就不算有谱不能叫离谱
Jack: Get out of here, this doesn't even count as having a score, can't call it ridiculous.
Nicous: 他没有背歌词
Nicous: He didn't memorize the lyrics.
Nicous: 他在玩茶流鸡我草
Nicous: He's playing around, damn it.
Jack: 让我猜他己经醉了
Jack: Let me guess, he's already drunk.
Jake:哈哈已经唱完了
Jake: Haha, he's already finished singing.
Shure: 没有没有我们这就是诗朗诵环节
Shure: No, no, this is our poetry recitation segment.
Jake:哎好好好
Jake: Okay, okay.
Shure: 难忘今宵表演者
Shure: Unforgettable Tonight performers.
Shure: Ego life全体成员
Shure: The entire Ego Life team.
Jake:啥 哈哈
Jake: What? Haha.
Katrina: 立的都爬了
Katrina: Everyone's up now.
Jack: 所以所以你们这一个礼拜
Jack: So, so you guys, this whole week...
女嘉宾:退票
Female Guest: Refund.
男嘉宾:都是天天这么精神病吗
Male Guest: Are you guys always this crazy every day?
Shure: 新来的朋友啊
Shure: Ah, a new friend.
Shure: 我们每天都很快乐
Shure: We are happy every day.
Shure: 来吧快来到美好的ego life吧
Shure: Come on, join the wonderful Ego Life.
Jack: 美好啊是没有好那个好吧
Jack: Wonderful, huh, more like not so wonderful.
Shure: ego life是一个
Shure: Ego Life is a...
Shure: 快乐的大家庭
Shure: Happy big family.
Shure: 是一个没有纷争的大家庭
Shure: It's a big family without conflicts.
Shure: 是一个完蛋
Shure: It's a... oh no.
Shure: 我被美女包围了的大家庭
Shure: A big family where I'm surrounded by beauties.
Shure: Ego life
Shure: Ego Life.
Jack: 就这句话比较现实
Jack: Now that's a more realistic statement.
Shure: 带给了我快乐
Shure: It brings me happiness.
Shure: 带给了我金币
Shure: It brings me coins.
Jake:Ego Coin
Jake: Ego Coin.